the U.S the UK and France supported a
nine-month extension of the Mandate
allowing Aid deliveries from Turkey to
Northwest Syria through the babal Hawa
border crossing but Russia voted against
that and China abstained instead Moscow
supported by Beijing proposed a
six-month extension and called for a
secretary-journal report on the
humanitarian effect of unilateral
Western sanctions on Syria those against
but now it was the U.S UK and France who
objected two votes in favor
three votes against
and ten abstentions it was a surprise
just minutes before the U.S had said the
crossing point was essential for
millions of people in need in Northwest
Syria the U.S ambassador blamed Russia
for the border crossings closure the
Russians have been bullies on this the
Syrian people want this assistance
I think the Assad regime wants this
assistance and they're going to have to
stand up and call for it the Russians
and the Chinese had argued that the
principle of the U.N security Council
governing Aid shipments to Syria should
be phased out in favor of Syrian
sovereignty and said that it was
hypocritical to express concern over the
plight of those in areas Beyond Syrian
government control in the Northwest
without also addressing the humanitarian
impact of unilateral Western sanctions
on the 11 million in the rest of Syria
who rely on International Aid and the
Syrian government agreed
him those who spoke about life and death
need to lift sanctions instead of crying
about syrians the Russians said they
would not support a rollover of the
previous mandate while a new agreement
has worked out but did suggest the
syrians could reopen babalhawa
themselves as they have two other border
crossings without U.N security Council
intervention by rewarding them with
either 12 or 9 months they're getting
nothing instead absolutely nothing
do you think Sarah will now you know add
bubble hallway to the other two things
that is for them to decide I think that
they may they may not but now it's in
the in their heads nonetheless the Swiss
who along with the Brazilians are
overseeing the UN Security council's
deliberations on the reopening of the
babal Hawa Crossing say they remain
confident that those discussions will
continue the Mandate for una deliveries
through the crossing expired on Monday
Al Jazeera the United Nations
Nur Kor mosh is at the babelhauer
Crossing along the Syria Tokyo border
ly a failure to extend Andrew the uh
Babu Hawaii Crossing has left Millions
who are currently living in the refugee
camps in a State of Shock and
disappointment actually at the U.N and
the security Council as
they were in somehow in a little bit of
hope that they will consider the latest
laws that the the people here in the
refugee camps and in the community have
endured after the latest catastrophic
earthquakes that struck the uh region of
course the absence of U.N delivered Aid
will have a dire humanitarian
consequences on the already worsening
humanitarian situation here in
Northwestern as Syria has two million uh
people are currently living in the
refugee camps and are a living off the
monthly food baskets that are being
provided by the uh food program in the
UN of course the ngos are also going to
suffer the consequences of this uh this
decision as uh as uh 100 of their fund
depends on the
un-8 coming through the Babel Hawa and
of course local humanitarian activists
condemned this decision and described it
as politicizing the humanitarian sector
in which will uh affect the lives of
millions who are currently living in the
refugee camps and are living off the uh
the food baskets and the uh Health
sector that is being provided to the
hospitals will be severely affected in
the area
Mustafa works on advocacy and
humanitarian initiatives in Syria and he
says continuous votes on Aid deliveries
to these Rebel held territories are
unnecessary and harmful to syrians
every few months we have the
International Community consensus by all
the other members of the security
Council minus uh China for example that
is abstained in in after the veto by
Russia Today everyone agrees that the
humanitarian Aid that the International
Community through the United Nations is
allocating for these syrians uh over 4
million in Northwest Syria
um we we can we give concessions in
order for Russia and the Assad regime to
allow another six months nine months 12
months three months to open the border
and that is completely unnecessary the
fact is uh that the United Nations does
not need a security Council resolution
simply to provide specifically
humanitarian Aid and the fact that we
are allowing Russia in the Assad regime
and to enter the politics of the U.N on
this and have the same people that
besiege and bombard these populations be
in charge of saying okay you can send
Aid across or not over border points by
the way they do not control in areas
that do they have no presence is is
really appalling what's really important
about border crossing it's the main
border crossing that has been
traditionally even allowed to be used by
the Russia and the Assad regime for the
UNA to enter Babel Hawa is that main
artery and it goes directly to idlib
Province a province where you have
millions of people including major
cities and towns and other things that
are in Desperate a need for this Aid
many of them internally displaced in ad
hoc camps with no access to
International bodies to support them
that's why this Aid is so important it's
for millions of people the majority of
which are our children and obviously
civilians